brought to you by PlayStation Store
access to the ultimate and games and
entertainment wats out and all those
crazy folks over at Nintendo done drop
some weird news today we were originally
going to talk about mario party today on
the show but there's a bunch of crazy
stuff came here today Randolph Ramsey
Justin hey Walden plain to me first of
all before we get into the mobile game
stuff what is this new Nintendo platform
what if anything do we know about it we
know everything about really now don't
ya we had a behind me we can talk about
poorest Nintendo came by this morning
yes Joe showed us yeah and that what
it's called the code name is the NX or
Nintendo ax stands for ten and they're
gonna put a money sign at the end of it
total beam it in Tendo which Jesus cries
which all wrong we're just lying
obviously because all we know those two
lens yes basically which I think with
what everyone else knows right now yeah
which is hey we're doing something we've
got a new piece of hardware that we're
working on and we're not gonna talk
about it till next year please
understand which I guess isn't really
news because I guess the assumption for
most people is yeah they've gotta be
working on something now in any and
they've said in interviews every company
has said as soon as we are done as soon
as this platform launches we begin work
on the next platform so it's basically
that this is saying they have a firmer
idea and they probably started more
hardcore into prototyping and yeah we'll
hear more in 2016 at least the code name
doesn't sound like a Wang yeah this time
yeah and they have kept code names
before avenue i'm trying to think was
the wii was revolution revolution is
that sorry Nick Coleman was project
often nintendo 64 I think the Super
Nintendo they kept the code name of
Super Nintendo alright so good code name
yeah right I've no idea what we use code
name I can't remember though that was
the revolution yeah oh sorry you sorry
dont worry yeah i don't think we did I
was coming out they were like it was a
pro kind of like the week sep there's
this top never look up we thought it was
the controller yeah and still the rest
of the consumers in the world think that
as well so and that's the exciting news
but it's also what we know the least
about yes because what they were
actually talking more about it
and definitely in a play to get
shareholders up is that they are going
to start developing games for mobile
devices they said in 20 early wanna
specifically said in 2013 we're not
gonna make games on smartphones because
and and we think that when you look at
the future of Nintendo later on you will
see that this was a good choice now 2015
yep he's basically said we're gonna make
games for smartphones yep because we
need to make money so are they gonna
make them themselves or what's this
parse partnership or now we've already
heard that in Nintendo is said
specifically their licensing out their
IP when other developers want to use
Nintendo or our zeldo mari or those
characters they're gonna be able to
we've already seen that with puzzles and
dragons with a mario theme like that's
not developed by Nintendo internally
that's developed by the puzzles &
Dragons team and we've seen that
previously we haven't seen it's probably
to the level that we're gonna see it for
a really long time like back in the 80s
when we add Mario games put on the
computer devices that nobody played are
those really terrible Zelda games that
on CD idea yeah specifically for this
though they partnered with a Japanese
mobile company which one of the biggest
sorta like mobile games development
companies in and called DNA and if you
ever been to a tokyo game show you'll
see you know like one of the biggest
boots they will always always gonna be a
DNA booth and it's always weird going
there and seeing all these like massive
array of games yeah you know we in the
Western press don't know anything about
the only one I know is rolando I think
they worked on no I don't even know like
most of the stuff is like more casual
right and is way too early targeted for
the japanese market so i guess you know
the assumption that world making here is
that the nintendo and DNA partnership is
going to result in games that are going
to come out in the west right and i
think some DNA stuff mostly nice stuff
actually just stays within the country
right so it's still bit of a question
mark as to what will actually hit
western markets but well i think the
bigger thing that we're gonna see from
this is not necessarily the games
they're coming out from it but but that
partnership in helping and helping I
think DNA is going to help nintendo
create an overall infrastructure that's
not good i mean we've already seen them
get rid of club nintendo yeah what
they're going to do is have a cohesive
vision which they've needed for so long
which they playing catch-up on and they
need a cohesive this isn't just our home
console and mobile games and 3ds games
like these need to all be brought
together and I
think that's something that Dean DNA is
going to help them with so that's a
common online infrastructure yeah that
works across yeah whatever consoles they
have in the future so it's just the one
thing you want ID throughout all event
and you know it's Nintendo you know
finally I guess catching up to you know
having those type of you know similar
services across the board yeah and you
know I think this is actually a pretty
good mood for them like you mention a
start notice the shareholder play and it
truly is because I think the stock went
up like $23 really it would like thirty
percent in this was what shareholders
been asking for for a long time and in
that sense they needed to do this too
because you know they're publicly traded
company I do have to really boss the
desktop seems to be doing fantastically
well as our bus and we're gonna see some
I mean to put it bluntly we're gonna see
some shitty games out of this we've
already seen stuff like Pokemon shuffle
that is on 3ds that is basically a match
3 game yeah with microtransactions and
we're gonna see more of that but I don't
think that's necessarily a bad thing if
that's the kind of thing that can keep
Nintendo afloat because of course like
why not chase after that that market
that's going to spend money on that and
if that gives you the money and the
freedom to keep making the games that we
love you as long as it doesn't shut out
that that creativity in that freedom
like this could be a really good thing
i've seen some people freaking out about
it especially the combination i guess
with DNA because there's this term do
you know you've lived in Japan before
gashapon is that like a it's some sort
of like term for those those those like
voles you get ahead of machines you kind
of put the money in and you get random
so like there was this thing that
happened a couple of years ago where a
digital or virtual gashapon became a
thing and DNA have been like done the
story forefront of that where you're
basically goading free-to-play games and
goading people to like just put in extra
money with the you know random almost
like a lottery system like you're just
getting like random prizes so so ketchup
on basically it correct me if I'm wrong
it's where you you pay a certain amount
of money and you get a drop you get an
item basically and what that is is
randomized right so yeah it does sort of
you know incentivize you I didn't get
the right thing I need to know to keep
putting money into it and I think I
games like Crossy Road like that's kind
of what that's doing right and we have
the same thing with a lot of Diablo I
mean we're not necessarily paying real
money into to those hardcore experiences
but you get the same thing with destiny
if we know the drops that you're getting
from those any world of warcraft played
into that at the very beginning where
you're not paying for you know of course
individual items but when you go on a
raid you're hoping that drop is the good
the thing that you really want and
that's what keeps you going to key
differences you're not paying those so
you you're just playing it because the
world of warcraft you're paying monthly
you're playing a flat fee and this is
basically saying well we can get more
money from people who want to spend a
whole lot on it and there are some
people who maybe we'll do this once a
month I just worry about things like for
instance the amoeba is where a Nintendo
have like created this thing which is
clearly like a you know super fan you
want to pay us some extra money because
the meebo is for all like they do that
don't actually do that much like in the
in terms of their like individual like a
bit like the technology isn't that so
far ahead and incredible it's more of
like a collector's items look I'm all
for this because I'm I'm selfish right
like I want Nintendo to keep making
games for me yeah and i think you know
lesson let's be frank if they keep going
the way they're going they're they're
not going to be able to do that for you
know for a long time right so they need
to expand their market they need to get
beyond the super fans which i think we
are where the types that actually buy
amiibo because you know we grew up in
nintendo we have this built-in passion
for the brand so they need to like find
new customers for that and i always go
back to my experience with my kids right
so I've got two kids you know I would
love them to play Nintendo games the
five-year-old is still a little bit
young all he does is play ipad games
because that's easy right you just point
and drag and do all that stuff and there
is one game there's like camp pokemon
yeah that is on iOS that he's playing
right now but i would love there was
some you know Kirby or mario game that
he could get into and I can try and you
know instill that same passion I have in
him on a platform that is already using
I don't need to graduate them to you
know a three days which is a lot harder
to use for kids right and we use so you
know III think it's a great move
hopefully the crappy games will be
limited I mean Nintendo has yeah you
know hopefully some quality assurance
yes maybe they just do this now bring
back the seal of approval of the thing
yeah you got it done and dusted it's
easy for us to be armchair analyst to be
an armchair CEO because we wanna like we
feel like I'm gonna make awesome
decisions and I don't have to worry
about keeping all these people were
giving me money happy
yeah but I Nintendo has to balance a lot
of things in that the frightening thing
is when you think about oh how much
they've [ __ ] up online their online
infrastructure leading up to now has
been garbage amiibo is used like that is
not a good model for anything does that
give me a lot of hope that they'll be
able to do like a no I always have hope
for Nintendo because they made I have
that nostalgia they mean so many great
things growing up they still continue to
make really fun experiences they made a
lot of mistakes though so I need you
still have to approach with caution they
could still completely make this a
terrible thing hopefully the combination
of them working with other partners will
you know to steer them in the right
direction I guess we'll have to wait mr.